I can honestly say there is nothing I
would rather be known as than the
people's author I've never heard that
and I'm thinking he got it from some
blog from some guy who was like
completely wasted on ecstasy and cheap
red wine when he said it but if it were
true I would love that and being a
person who believes that all truth is
paradox and contradiction I just get as
sucked in as any writer into you know
the jungle drums of publication and
wishing that I were on the Today show
this morning instead of David Remnick
and how it's not fair and how it's not
fair that he's you know this and that in
the ds1 fresh air and so you know I have
a kind of a bitterness that goes along
with this sense of being the people's
author and really feeling like a
missionary most of time and just want
you to tell people the truth of my
experiences that were all a lot more
alike than we are different and that if
I share something that seems kind of
intimate or autobiographical it's
because I assume it's true for you too
and I've told it so many times and
everybody said oh yeah me too I'm not
telling anything that isn't true for
most of us and it just has to do with
that we can seem sort of spiritual and
you know hippie-dippie like I think I
come across and tree hugger and San
Francisco and all that and at the same
time be sort of enraged that that this
the New York glitterati are getting the
great spots in the media the week that
I'm on tour on the East Coast
I would say the most important thing is
to pretend that you're above all of that
but certainly I'm just finding this week
we're taping this the day of public the
publication and I'm finding just so much
manipulation and kind of desperado stuff
going on inside me and I'm trying to
suck people into my web and I am trying
to use old contacts kind of as if in the
most casual way to try to get them to
shoehorn me on to CNN maybe later today
after i saw in stock at the river head
office so I you know I find a lot of
stuff inside me this thing is I don't
eat I'll be 56 at the end of the week
and I don't act on it as much as I used
to before I would have done it all and I
would have just been dancing as fast as
I could to try to suck in and please
everyone and seduce everyone and push
everyone hard or to get and I just feel
I feel too tired you know my I'm kind of
a key from the long flight and so the
impulse is there and probably this side
of the grave it just comes with the
territory it comes with the turf of
being a well-known writer is that you
know I have a disease called more and if
i have a huge audience I'd like a bigger
audience maybe a slightly more
illustrious audience maybe if Susan
sonntag were alive she would want to be
my best friend